what up
peeps it is march 4th
2021 i'm dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message i've been awake
since
5 30 a.m this morning because i was
on america's newsroom with dana perino
and bill hammer on fox news
like 6 30 i had set my alarm to six
but then you know when you set the alarm
for the super early wake up and then you
wake up before that and then you can't
go back to sleep and you just look at
your alarm
non-stop for a half hour so i was up at
5 30.
but despite that i'm here for you
and we've got a big show not a little
show not an average show
a big huge spectacular show for you
a quick reminder guys click that
subscribe
button up there and tap that
notification bell so you actually see
our videos
in your feed or at least you have a
chance to see our videos
in the feed we are doing a q a today i
was gonna do just a regular show today
but then
we saw this video yesterday of joe biden
almost
doing a q a and then i thought we should
do a q a because
joe's not really doing a q a we're going
to show you that video
and then we got a ton of questions at
reubenreport.locals.com which i'm going
to plow into and it's actually a really
nice mix of questions
and i'm in the mood to answer some
questions so we're going to get to that
before we do though guys i want to talk
to you
about bonner private wine i've got a
bottle right here
if you're a health conscious red wine
lover like me here's how to make your
next drink
10 times healthier down in argentina
they make this really dark
red wine from malbec grapes grown at 9
000 feet
they've been lab tested and these wines
they found out that they contain up to
10 times the levels of a longevity
and heart health nutrient called
resveratrol
resveratrol's powerful stuff it pops up
again and again in studies on longevity
heart health and brain health these
wines also have 90
less sugar fewer chemicals fewer
additives plus if you love steak and bbq
like i do
red wine has been shown to actually make
red meat healthier
but the best thing about these wines is
that they taste great with notes of
blackberry
leather cherry and smoke as you guys
know i do a lot of steaks around here
adam corolla said i made him the best
steak he's ever had in his life
and that guy's got some dough and we
enjoy some red wine while we're doing it
today the guys at freethinkerwine.com
are giving you 50 off their best malbecs
and you'll also get 50 off free shipping
wine makes a great gift even
if it's a gift to yourself i do often
give myself the gift of wine
just visit freethinkerwine.com today
that's freethinkerwine.com today
and now back to me all right so the
reason we're doing the q
a today we've been trying to do them
about one one a week but because i did
this live event
uh earlier in the week on tuesday night
in l.a we had about 100 people there and
i was obviously answering a lot of
questions in person and
chatting people i was like ah maybe we
won't do a q a today
but then this video went viral yesterday
now before we throw to the video
joe biden i talked about this yesterday
he's about 50 some odd days into his
presidency he has not
given a full press conference where he
takes questions
from the crowd he's uh from the from the
crowd from the press
well i guess they're a crowd now or
whatever they are the few people that
would sit in that room with him
um he hasn't done one of those he also
did not give a stay to the union which
every president for the last 80 plus
years has given a state of the union
in their first month in office so
they're kind of hiding him i mean that
that's pretty obvious
but then there are these weird moments
where he's just supposed to talk and
suddenly he like kind of accidentally
opens the door for questions and uh this
is yesterday and just to clarify it's
his 43rd day in office we like to be
exact
around here let's take a look thank you
thank you
and i'm happy to take questions if
that's you i'm supposed to do nance
whatever you want me to do
happy to take question nance if that's
what you want me to do
it's whatever you want me to do now
nance apparently is a staffer over there
at the white house
but does and then they immediately cut
them off so do you see what happened
they're like who's really in charge
do you think i don't mean to be partisan
i don't mean to mock anyone or anything
like that
or mock mental health but do you think
joe biden's in charge
like does anyone in their right mind
think joe biden's in charge and where is
the mainstream media
why has no one at the beloved new york
times said anything about this why has
no one
at the reputable news organization known
as cnn
said anything about this that that
putting aside the cognitive stuff it's
just
clear he's not in charge nance nance can
i take a couple questions
vance maybe maybe and then they just cut
him off and then they just move on
because they know the media
won't even ask about that just for a
little more info on what i just touched
on about presidents
uh giving press conferences the last 15
presidents have all given a press
conference in the first 33 days
joe biden as i just said is now in his
43rd day he has not given a press
conference
it's fairly obvious that they are going
to hide him as much as possible it's not
gonna happen
and then we get jen pasaki who is just
such
just so stiff and and you know they're
all dishonest
i don't say they're all dishonest
because dana perino is a former
white house press secretary and she's
become a friend of mine and i just did
her show this morning
and uh she's on our show next week
because she's got a new book coming out
so it's not not dishonest but the the
the job of the press secretary obviously
is to curate the truth it's to sort of
hide certain things
let you know some other things clarify
some other things jen pasaki just comes
off as patently dishonest and that seems
like it's about the best we're gonna get
in this administration so
joe joe wants to answer questions or at
least he doesn't remember to not
answer questions and uh they're they're
just not having any of it
okay we've got about 20 questions to get
to before i do it real quick guys
uh you know spring is in the air and you
know what that means
swimsuit season is just around the
corner you might be thinking i know dave
but how can i tame my sweet tooth at the
same time
do not fret people i've got just the
solution for you built bar is the secret
to eating healthier food
while also eating tastier food built
bars are low calorie low sugar high
protein high fiber
great for the keto diet i can actually
lose or maintain weight while indulging
in a yummy treat healthy has never been
this delicious
biltmars tastes like candy and come in
18 amazing flavors including mint
brownie
and cherry barcia cherry barcia how
about that
my personal favorite is cookies and
cream you guys know that we've got a
whole bunch of them right here i've got
the cookies and cream
right here uh and i know with
restaurants open up guys it'll be
tempting to indulge but we also need to
shed those additional quarantine pounds
which is why build bars are the perfect
alternative to pie
for the health conscious guy each bar
contains 110-160 calories 16 to 20 grams
of protein
three to five net carbs you don't need
the luck of the irish or a pot of gold
to buy a built bar go to builtbar.com
and use promo code ruben to get 20 off
your next order
use promo code ruben for 20
off at billbar.com and now back to me
all right so i think i'm going to do a
uh
i think i'm going to do an uncensored q
a i think i'm gonna do an uncensored q a
right now for the for everybody i'm
gonna do just an uncensored i'm just
gonna answer questions
from you guys nance would that be okay
you see what we did there you see you
see who's playing along at home huh
okay here we go guys conservative chicas
79
says why isn't anyone covering critical
race theory
being implemented in the armed forces
there are diversity inclusion
mandatory training sessions in the army
well i like to believe that i've been
talking a little bit about it i know
that my friends at the blaze have been
talking about a little bit i know that
the guys are the daily wire and some of
my other far right radical friends have
been talking about it
yes critical race theory has now been
injected back into the system
so when we talk about systemic racism
which we haven't had there was no
systemic racism in the armed forces
as a matter of fact remember the orange
guy he had banned
critical race theory in federal
institutions not only in federal
institutions
like the armed forces but also with
businesses
that do business with federal
institutions
you could not have these uh diversity
and inclusion programs
uh that was an executive order that he
signed now we can all debate the
validity of executive orders and and why
they're
problematic as the kids say because one
guy signs him
new guy comes in four years later he
just unsigns them and signs some new
stuff
that being said trump did get critical
race theory out of a lot of the
institutions and
joe biden brought it right back in so
that's right the diversity and inclusion
stuff is right back in it's in our armed
forces
when training is happening now with our
armed forces and when they're selecting
for people
to get promotions and all sorts of stuff
obviously now they are going to be
looking at
skin color they are going to be looking
at gender and gender identity and all of
those things
that is not to say i have to stop doing
the
the uh the exclusions on this you know
like just making
like everyone knows everyone knows it is
not to say
that you shouldn't get a job because
you're black or you shouldn't get a job
because you're trans or gay
or a lesbo or whatever it is that's all
well and good
but we should be hiring the best people
based on qualifications those are the
people that should be making their way
up uh important institutions such as the
armed forces
they shouldn't be looking and going oh
you know we actually should have 33
black people and 33 percent latino
people and 33
white people or forget 33 that would be
too even we should just have the exact
same percentage as we have of those
people
in in the united states that's how we
should uh make up our army it's crazy so
this is something that we should talk
about more
and one of the things that i that i
often bring up when i talk about this
which is an idea that
uh originally i originally got from my
friend my friend peter bogosian who as
you guys know he's a
philosophy professor up at portland
state and he's been one of the most
outspoken people against
diversity inclusion and critical race
there and everything else is that once
these institutions whether it's a
business or a governmental institution
or whatever it might be
once they inject the ideas of diversity
inclusion once they hire a diversity
inclusion officer
once they start putting resources
towards that you are now
taking resources away from whatever it
is you do so if you sell sneakers
you're now more focused on race and
gender and sexuality than just selling
the best damn sneaker
as possible if you're in the army you're
now focused
on hiring people based on these things
that we might have in the old days
called racism that the obsessive focus
with race
uh instead of building the best you know
most slim
trim army that is possible so it's a
huge problem i'll keep talking about it
and and i need you guys
not i need you need to talk about it too
to your friends and family and have them
understand
that these really terrible ideas are
infiltrating the entire system
a steamboat says has there ever been a
case in history
where the people limiting speech and
banning burning books
have turned out to be the good guys that
is a great great
question i i cannot think of an instance
where banning books
hiding information you know destroying
the ability for
for a society to exchange ideas i cannot
think of a situation where that could
possibly be good i mean we can all
picture the images of what was happening
in nazi germany when they were having
bonfires with books and in essence we're
having digital book burnings right now
there was some guy who
named his best-selling book from last
year don't burn this book
very handsome by the way that fell i
forget his name but the point of that
book
by that handsome fella was that when you
say don't burn this book it's like
the things that i laid out in that book
were basic
i think moderate for the most part
moderate positions
things that were completely in line with
the way the country was founded and the
way it has run for so long
and those are now dangerous ideas and
it's not like we have book burnings in
the traditional sense yet right so even
in the last few days as the
uh publishing house that produces dr
seuss books they've said these six books
are no longer
going to be published they're not out
there burning them right even even the
crazy wokesters aren't out there burning
dr seuss books yet
but when you stop publishing things
because suddenly they don't fit the
norms of the day
yes dr seuss was a big racist when he
was writing about the cat and the
whatever
in 1942 like it's just so silly right
and it's like wait a minute let's
pretend even even if even if i will go
so far
for you wokesters because i know you
guys if i give you an inch you're not
going to take more than that right
i'll go so far and say that those books
those six books they were evil they were
racist they were homophobic they were
transphobic
nazi-ish right they had a little mind
comp type stuff in them
well if if it's legit to get rid of
those six well then wouldn't you get rid
of his other 33 because
even if they don't include that stuff
he's a nazi and we've got to take out
the work
by the nazi i mean that's why none of
this makes sense and we're in a
very bizarre cultural revolution right
now
i mean that's really what's happening we
are watching every norm be absolutely
destroyed
but tomorrow we will be
doing a show just on this we're going
back to the panel on fridays
and we have a live panel all about book
burning uh the history of book burning
the history of dangerous ideas
uh and we will have abigail schreier who
you guys know i had her on the show
who just wrote a book about the the
epidemic of young girls transitioning
and that became a very dangerous book
that at one point target pulled from the
shelves and it was only until
an outcry against the non-outcry in the
first place
that allowed that book to get back in
there we'll have nancy rommelman on and
we will have michael knowles
and we're gonna do all a whole half hour
about
modern and digital book burning uh lynn
says do you think the sexual harassment
issues with cuomo
are just a smoke screen to get people's
minds off the thousands of elderly
patients that he killed you know i
addressed this yesterday because i think
there's something interesting
and also kind of dangerous happening
with cuomo right now look
we were told for years believe all women
we were told me too
and you got to believe all women and and
if someone accuses you of something you
got to step down you got to get out of
the way now we know
of course this only worked one way it
worked to take out conservatives it
worked to take out
you know people like brett kavanaugh we
know that and then when it hap when
when uh democrats or left-leaning people
are accused of it then oh well that
we should probably find out more
information if we need a special
investigation and blah blah blah
now i am not sitting here saying that
that
andrew cuomo is some kind of pervert or
that he has done anything or not done
anything there are three women with
sexual harassment claims
from what i understand none of them are
of a physical nature it's all about
things that he said and jokes
that he made okay now i'm not defending
that i'm not even casting judgment on
any of that and i don't know all the
motives of these women
i'm just saying if you guys want to play
with the rules that you set up right so
cuomo these are the rules that you guys
the lefties the progressives set up
about believe all women so you know
you kind of got to go down by by the
rules that you set up
i think that is one way that that let's
say right-leaning people can start
gaining the culture war back is just
make them play by their rules
two things actually you make the left
play by the rules that the
that the left sets up and you also don't
play by them
do not play by their rules you know they
they are out to destroy everybody and
and with when you add the big tech
element
of how they can spread rumors and
innuendo and send mobs after you and
everything else it's like
let them play by their rules and also
don't play by their rules that's
that's a pretty good twosome right there
as far as
the the real scandal here it's the
latter part of your question which is
this issue by sending elderly people
back into nursing homes we know that
covid
spread okay we i mean this is not up for
debate
google it read many sources we know that
this was a policy that he
uh instituted and that's for that's for
the people of new york
that's either for the for the new york
legislature to deal with if they want to
impeach him
or for it's for the people of new york
to basically create such a situation
that he has to step down or just not
re-elect him at the very least
or whatever but yes the the sexual
harassment thing seems like a little bit
of a side bar
and you can see the right pouncing on it
they do pounce a lot those people on the
right
they're always pouncing um but you can
see them kind of pouncing on it
because i think they just see blood in
the water and unfortunately that's the
game that politics has become but
to me personally the issue about what
happened with covet and the elderly
patients and his complete mismanagement
that genuinely cost people their lives
that's far worse than
than the sexual harassment accusations
and i would also
add to that that it's because none of
them are physical in nature from what i
understand so
it's it's words and i'm not defending
any of those words we've all we've all
made off-color jokes right we've all
done it
i'm not defending any of that but if it
was a physical thing in nature as if he
had you know if a woman was coming out
saying
you know he raped me that might be a
little bit different but
i think you got the point uh ali naam
says what's your taste in art
style media artist or just one painting
that really touches you i love this
question because you know i had jordan
peterson obviously on this week and one
of the things that we discussed
is art and beauty and why it's so
important why we need to see
beautiful things to sort of reach out
and and find the transcendent
and uh i i actually love art so we're
gonna put up a couple images here
so the first image that you're seeing
there that is a piece that used to sit
behind me
uh there's the old set that used to sit
in my garage and
uh all of the pieces that we're about to
show you are
by a spectacular artist by the name of
kailyn rosejanet it's
kalynnrosejanet.com i think we're going
to show a link there
now she does happen to be my my
sister-in-law full disclosure
but she's a wonderful artist we're going
to show you a couple more so uh the
you're seeing which one am i looking at
right now i'm looking at the right one
so that
that piece uh sat behind the the guests
on
our old set it's now hanging in my house
this black piece that you're looking at
over there
is the is the second piece uh to that
first one that we showed
and then uh on the right there you're
looking at an amazing resin pour that's
in our house that's about a five
foot giant circular resin pour and then
uh finally one more that is a hyperspace
which we commissioned her to do and that
is i think five
feet by eight feet which we have hanging
in our house and every single person
that comes into our house is just blown
away by that one and just put that one
up for one more second the uh
the hyperspace that thing was a freaking
labor of lover to paint that by hand get
all those lines right like that thing
took hours and hours and hours
anyway she's a truly spectacular artist
and you can get prince i i don't get a
commission on any of this stuff yes
she is my sister-in-law but i think the
work stands on its own
um you can get prints of hyperspace and
some of the other stuff that we used to
have on my
set that that white one that we put up
there um
that actually yeah that used to sit
behind me on the set that's actually in
our bedroom right now
and anyway to to really get to your
question though
um there is a real importance to art
that i think we've forgotten you know we
don't have great art anymore we don't
have great comedy
um when was the last time you heard some
really new music that really moved you
um so i love like it's great you know we
host a lot of dinner parties here highly
illegal dinner parties with other
you know right-wing radical criminals
and we might be doing one in a few days
actually
and uh and i love when people come in
and they see something in your house
that like moves them in some way so one
of the
new rules that jordan has in beyond
order which came out this week
is that you should have one room in your
house that that basically restores
some beauty and if you if you can't have
one room or you live in a
uh you know you just live in a little
one bedroom whatever
you if you could just have a corner of a
bedroom just something so that
throughout your day you see a little bit
of beauty
uh that helps you get to the to the
thing
to the thing that's beyond us uh so i i
do love art i'd love to know what
what you guys love and actually a bunch
of people have been posting different
things of
art and i met somebody the other night
at the live meet and greet who's uh
painting a picture of clyde so yeah art
people
art it's good there you go uh chris says
heard on your podcast that you're
planning to hit florida in april just
want to make sure that miami is on a
list
so we can come out and support you yes i
will be doing a comedy club tour
i think we're gonna do about seven stops
probably about 10 days in florida i'm
just gonna bounce all over to as many
shows as i possibly can
i wanted to do theater shows there and
get you know to do a couple thousand
people
and we would have done like three shows
instead of obviously comedy clubs are
smaller
so we can do more shows um but the
theater situation is just crazy right
now because of covid and there's all
these extra expenses
because of testing people and and how
many people can be there and it's just
all even the comedy clubs it's like
confusing how to do it but yes we will
be doing a show
in miami we're gonna we're gonna really
bounce all over the state probably five
to seven shows
i'm super psyched to get out there and
and you know what i'll have two or three
jokes but mostly what we're gonna do
i'm going to get up there and we're
going to do a little of this i'm going
to talk about what's on my mind i'm
going to talk to you guys maybe i'll
give away some stuff get some of you
guys on stage
and just have a good time imagine that
human beings having a good time
out at some sort of venue drinking and
eating what a world
candace says i say we have a mask
burning you in
yeah i can't wait i can't wait man if
they ever open this ridiculous state
that i live in california i cannot wait
to i will can we get one of those elon
musk flame throwers
can we all right we're gonna we're gonna
look into an elon musk flame but
otherwise i got just like a little match
and i'm just gonna burn my little bass
with the match
uh but yes it will be great and again if
you wanna wear a mask
wear a mask all good texas is open now
guess what they're not going to
shoot you if you wear a mask they're not
even going to shame you probably
if you feel that you want to wear a mask
and take whatever precautions you want
to take in your home or place of work
get to it but they're taking the risk
texas greg abbott the governor there is
going okay
we've seen numbers dropped now we're
going to open up and by the way
i tweeted this out this morning but you
know even if i i suspect that there
won't be like some
massive outbreak of kovid where suddenly
we're going to watch tons of
of young people die i don't anticipate
that happening
because texas has been largely open
anyway and florida's been largely open
anyway
but even if you see some little spike in
numbers
perhaps that gets us closer to herd
immunity which is a phrase that we were
talking about a year ago which we don't
talk about now
now we talk about two masks and we can
get back to normalcy in a year from now
so this is this this is the system
actually working the way it was supposed
to that governors are making decisions
for their people and wise people live in
states with wise governors that says a
little something about me
but we're not doing therapy today anya
says what will it take for people to
stop being so afraid of the virus
it's a similar question you know that is
the thing though that i'm really worried
about because you're asking sort of like
when you talk about fear it's like the
psychological makeup of people i think
that that is what is sort of
being burst forth into the zeitgeist
right now is we're learning that people
have
very very different fear centers a
certain amount of people
have medical fears and by the way that's
not just all that's not just all
unwarranted if
you're older if you have comorbidities
if if you're out of shape if you don't
have good health care i mean there's all
sorts of things that are completely
legit
there's a certain type of person i would
say that thinks that
the machine that the machine can just
take care of you
and keep you safe and it will do it out
of
the goodness of its heart and that the
leaders and the people in charge
are all know what they're doing and
that's partly why we always forget what
they said two weeks ago because often
they don't know what they're doing and
that's that's part of science is
playing a little catch up with new
information and everything else but but
i'm interested in this question because
by talking about the fear
it's like when i think about it this way
when i was in florida it was very
obvious to me that the people
at least the people i was around and i
was out and about and on the beach
at restaurants and at bars and people
say hi to me it was very clear to me
that
people aren't sort of dominated by fear
i met a lot of old people the last night
we were there we were at this mexican
joint indoors
and there was a couple these guys were
probably
85 years old i told the story this was
an earlier night i told the story about
how we were sitting there with my
my sister and her young kids and this
old couple comes up to us
and this elderly woman elderly she's
pointing her like old bony finger
oh that's a cute kid over there talking
about my nephew
and i turned and she literally stuck her
finger in my mouth and it was like
yeah and i survived i'm pretty sure she
survived but that the culture of fear in
florida
is much less than a place like los
angeles specifically and california more
broadly that when i go to the
supermarket i can still tell
people are afraid i had we had meg and
kelly over for dinner the other night
and i
ran out to get a bottle of tequila
before she got here and i'm online
and the store was basically empty and
some guy yelled at me because i wasn't
standing exactly on the sticker
and it's a combination of like fear and
control
and frustration and anger and then what
i've noticed it does to me
personally is that then when i'm out in
these places
i'm kind of like a little trigger happy
i'm like yeah i'm like looking around
like yeah you just say something to me
and i'll tell you what's what
i'll give you the old one too you know
and that that's not good either that you
know so again people should do what they
think is right and stores should do what
they think is right and then i think
the rest is up the rest is out of our
control
people uh gina the nomad says are you a
morning person
midday guy or night owl you know i'm at
my best it depends what i'm doing i'm at
my best for work
in the morning i've mentioned this a
couple times like i get up
i pee first then i come downstairs i
make some coffee
i get clyde in the backyard feed him and
then i'm going like and i'm going and
going and going and obviously with doing
shows and running a tech company and
everything else like i have no shortage
of things to do and
even if i have a rare second i usually
don't because then i suddenly realize i
got to catch up on something else or
emails
and there's so much going on with locals
right now and on the investment side and
we're going to make a couple
announcements in the next
couple weeks so i would say in terms of
work i'm definitely at my best in the
morning and i
and i love just like plowing through the
day
and then uh michael and connor who are
here my my director
and my producer they know it's like when
we're done like if we sh
finish after a long day of shoots four
or five o'clock i'm like man
i don't want to talk for the rest of the
day and then often sometimes at dinner
david will be like you know what what's
going on today or want to talk about the
news and i'm like
i'm like you could talk but maybe just
give me a break i don't want to talk
right now
um but then i also i really enjoy the
evening i actually really enjoy the
evening i
you know i i love some red wine we
talked about red wine earlier so i love
just
popping a bottle a red wine and we've
got a little fire pit in the back and
and just sitting back there and relaxing
i don't really watch a lot of tv anymore
there's really nothing on i
you know i always joke that i watch i
literally watch the same three things
that i watch in 1989 i watch
uh the golden girl seinfeld and the
simpsons
just repeats from basically back then
and i watch old basketball games
so productive during the day midday you
know the midday the midday is the midday
but i like a little a little evening
relaxation as well
storm huffman says are conservatives
gonna go
through what the left and deranged
liberals went through four years ago
are there other self-critiques we should
consider before just flipping out
yeah you know what's happening right now
i think this is an interesting question
because you know
the left has gone so bananas the
woksters have gone so bananas there's
been such a decimation
of the good liberals who are just like
all you know i always use the order 66
like the jedi spread throughout the
galaxy they don't know how to get in
touch with each other they don't know
where they are
everyone's kind of shell-shocked like
what the hell happened and in effect
if you're an old-school liberal i would
say you're you're a modern
conservative uh somebody might be
writing a book about that as we speak
speaking of being busy during the day um
but what the what the new i don't like
saying new right i would say what this
new
conservative movement has to do is is go
how do we
become the biggest tent possible because
it's all of us
verse woke it's all of us were spoke but
how
what parameters do we have to have on
that meaning when i say all of us it's
like well we don't want kkk members
right you don't want kkk members
and then there are there are deep issues
that need to be dealt with in that
meaning
okay now you're going to have and and
you've had them for years you're going
to have
gay conservatives guys like rick
grinnell these people exist
right somebody like me these people
exist somebody like douglas murray
these people exist well how does how
does that square away with say the more
traditional
religious conservative what a great
thing to talk about like if you could
agree on the basic building blocks that
we want to live
in a free open society well then then
that's a spectacular place do we all
have to agree
exactly on what religion we are or the
way we live our life or all that that
doesn't strike me as
very conservative actually but that's
that's a great place to fight
i would say in terms of um self-critique
so that you don't become as hysterical
you know every day we wake up and
something crazy has happened so every
day you wake up and like
like who had it on their bingo card that
three days ago we were gonna wake up and
they're taking out
mr potato head right and then the two
days ago they're taking out dr
seuss this thing is gonna keep coming
and as somebody pointed out you know
with all the
so we get rid of the land of lakes lady
we get rid of aunt jemima we get rid of
uncle ben so we're just taking black
people and
and people of color off all of the
things in the supermarket
so now when you go to a supermarket
you'll only see products with white
people
and that's because of the woksters that
seems like something white supremacists
would want wouldn't white supremacists
only want
rice with white people and syrup with
white people and the rest of it or now
it's not even that they're putting white
people on those things
now they give you just like the generic
company name what's the what did aunt
jemima
go to she's now the pearl mill company
or something like that like it's all
just so ridiculous but i think for
for anyone that's non-woke the challenge
is how do you address it how do you
show people the absurdity of it without
becoming hysterical without being
obsessed by it
you know without getting lost on twitter
and trust me i i struggle with that
because i see the nonsense
and then you know i'm looking at my
phone i'm like do i have to point this
[ __ ] ridiculous thing out to you
people again like how
often do we have to do it i felt that
that was an appropriate f-bomb there
we've been trying to no not no all right
all right that's it that's the one for
the week all right what's next what's
next
uh oh uh nuclear patrick says although
jp's books jordan peterson's books are
packed with insights
i feel uncomfortable with his view of
life as centered and suffering
you and you appear genuinely exuberant
and optimistic
so how do you feel about this well i
basically agree with jordan's premise
that that life
is tough there's a lot of suffering and
you got to do the work to get out of it
and we've all been in all of those
places right we've all been
in the dark place the sunken place i
think is what the kids call it we've all
been
we've all been there we've all had
whatever struggles we have
coming to grips with yourself being
addicted to drugs struggling with stuff
in your family all of those things right
like
whatever your stuff is and it always
feels like because it's yours it's like
monumentally huger than anyone else's
we've all had all of that stuff so i do
think life
it's not that life is suffering it's
that it takes work
not to be suffering and i think jordan
with these two books and with his
lectures and everything else that he's
done i think he probably has done the
best job of anyone in a modern sense
to say to people yeah there's suffering
but you don't have to suffer
and here are some of the tools to get
through that and of course as you know
he's working through those things
himself he never pretended
that he was a perfect you know humanoid
robot that had conquered everything and
has he has his own struggles and that if
anything to me
where i see this criticism oh he didn't
act perfectly a guy who wants you to
to live better and he didn't act
perfectly it's like well there's no such
thing
do you think that a guy who's telling
you about the challenges in life
the ways to get yourself back in order
do you think that a guy who could write
that book effectively
uh never struggled with anything like
it's just a it's a crazy premise i think
i find that criticism really bizarre um
as for how i
appear exuberant and optimistic you know
it it took
work it actually took work but you know
if i if i remove sort of the
the general state of the world and that
i'm worried about
um you know like the future of western
society and what kind of world i'm going
to welcome my children into and that
sort of thing
if i just look at sort of what my
day-to-day life although i'm getting
into fights with people while buying
tequila at the supermarket
like i love what i'm doing i love the
businesses that i've built i love my
day-to-day i wake
up with purpose because i like doing
work the lights are going crazy maybe
it's a sign
you seeing that guys the maybe it's a
sign someone's giving me a sign all
right
oh we lowered some lights okay there we
go um but i think if
if you just got to find something you
want to do and go get it and it ain't
going to be easy but if you just
try to find that thing and you just try
to get there even if you don't get
that thing the the journey will open up
some other things i think that's
i think that's really the key to the
whole damn thing uh all right just a
couple more
uh phillip hughes says with all the
celebrities who have gotten into the
adult beverage business
have you thought about creating dave
rubin's it's bananas banana liqueur
i should do that i really should do that
i've talked actually to a whole bunch of
wineries about doing like a reuben
report red
or ruben red some some version of that
we it's just tough to figure out like
truly like how financially it makes
sense
if you're not going to be in stores and
you're doing it just mail order and how
many bottles people have to buy on like
a whole bunch of that and as i said i'm
kind of busy uh but
it's bananas banana liqueur i like that
i will put that on the list of
stuff that we're doing uh michelle says
what made you choose august as the month
you disconnect this is going to be the
last question and i
think it's the right one to end on you
know when i started doing the off the
grid thing in august which i've done for
four years and i
will do again this year um even though
this past
august was bizarrely the easiest one to
do because everything was locked down we
actually did move
a couple miles away so we were busy with
moving but it was very easy just not to
be
on my phone or paying attention to
anything and you know being out and
about where
you know at the gym where you see all
the tvs but i wasn't going to the gym or
if you go to a burger joint there
they got cnn on or something i wasn't
doing that i wasn't in airports so i
wasn't seeing
uh you know the news and any of that
kind of stuff i chose august because it
seems to me i wrote a little bit about
this
in in don't burn this book that august
you have two moments
um i would say throughout the year where
there's great opportunity to shut down
i would say august as a month because
it's the it's obviously the last month
of the summer usually that last two
weeks or so it's between when
you know kids are maybe end in camp
going back to school like everyone
families seem to be calming down
traveling a little bit more
i also really want people to be able to
get off that hamster wheel of politics
and i always thought that like if there
was ever a time to do it
it would be august because people are
happier in the summer and you have more
chance to go to the beach
and be outdoors and enjoy yourself so i
don't need to like you know just
endlessly
pump out content for you guys you know
we do tape some stuff in advance
um obviously but like we try to scale it
back a little bit and i always say to
my guys even though they're working
throughout august it's like if we can do
as
if you guys can finish all the work of
august you know in the first week
august then congratulations you got
three weeks off too um
so so i do august just because i think
there's something right about that sort
of end to summer feeling to get off the
machines and all that kind of stuff but
i think the other opportunity for that
if you can't do a month like i get it
most people cannot do a month
obviously um and fortunately i've built
enough of a of a good team around me
that i'm able to do it but i think the
other opportunity if you ever want to
just try the off the grid thing i think
there's two opportunities
one is just try it for a weekend
and i know it's hard like if i said to
you right now you can't look at your
phone for the next 10 hours
right you can't look at your phone for
the next five hours like that
that would be like a very bizarre
feeling and you'd be
having phantom rings and going into your
pocket and all that stuff
but that's really crazy because 20 years
ago we did not all have these things
in our pockets i remember i got my first
phone it was a little candy bar black
and white nokia
you know all you could do is play snake
on it uh i got it right before 9 11.
okay so that's basically 20 years ago
not even 20 years ago at this point and
think how different the world is
so i would say if you if you're
interested in the off the grid thing try
to just do a weekend
and it doesn't mean you know you don't
have to do it all the way like if you if
you need your phone because
you have family around or you know you
want to make sure to
pick up an important call that's one
thing but but how about just don't do
social media for a weekend like just
don't check emails for a weekend just
try that and then the other part of it
is that i think the other opportunity
besides the august opportunity
is basically from christmas eve
to new year i think is a great
opportunity everyone's kind of shutting
down i always find that people are
sort of at their best selves at that
time you know i know the holidays can be
kind of rough for people but i
hopefully if you get a little spirit of
the season in you whether you celebrate
christmas or not
and that there's like a good opportunity
to like kind of end the year on like
just like a more calm disconnected note
i think there's a great opportunity to
do it there
so i get it not everyone can do august
although a bunch of people did join me
uh for it this year and i have a feeling
more people are last year and i'm
feeling more people will do it this year
um but try the weekend thing i i try it
i try it almost every weekend you know
some every now and again some weird
things happen or
my phone will blow up because something
happened and i feel like i have to throw
in something
but if you can't even do that then then
try the the christmas to new year's
situation
all right guys tomorrow uh we are doing
a special book
burning panel with abigail schreier
michael knowles
and nancy rommelman if you haven't seen
nancy's prageru video
do you what's the title of the video do
we know the title of the video we'll get
that in just a sec
uh it's really uh just phenomenal um but
we're gonna do a half hour panel
live we're back to being live we had
pre-taped last week we're back to being
live on that tomorrow
my full interview with jordan peterson
is up right here
on the youtube and of course it's
available ad free of
reubenreport.locals.com and we've been
clipping you know we always do two or
three clips per
episode um but for this jordan one we
are doing a little bit more than that so
clip four with jordan went up this
morning on youtube
oh and nancy's uh prageru video which is
really spectacular is called how to
become
a dangerous person and we could probably
all use a little bit more of that spirit
these days instead of being
how to be a cowardly person which is
what we're all hearing all the time
uh maybe how to be a dangerous person
and uh conor work with me here if
i'm gonna maybe take some more questions
right now
what do you think i'm gonna just take
some more guys would it be okay if i
took